we are finally in an election year so
for our main story tonight let's look at
voting the cornerstone of American
democracy the unshakable principle that
everyone should have an equal vote even
idiots even this guy now I know it's
painful but his votes should count as
much as yours it should count as much as
the presidents that's what America is
all about now in recent years some
states have made voting easier for
instance three states now hold their
elections almost entirely by mail and 30
states plus DC now let you register to
vote online
sadly others have gone in the opposite
direction because depending on who you
are and where you live you may face new
obstacles to voting this November thanks
to among other things the Supreme
Court's decision to weaken the Voting
Rights Acts for instance since 2011
seven states have curtailed early voting
and 13 have added requirements the
voters show some kind of ID at the polls
and the lawmakers pushing those voter ID
laws claimed they are just simple
common-sense measures it is common sense
that you would use picture ID to protect
the integrity of the voting process it's
an ID
everyone has an ID the people that are
homeless the people that go to vote they
get sick they go to the hospital they
buy they buy stuff they need ID I'm
proud that North Carolina has joined the
34 other states to enact a common-sense
voter ID law that that isn't going to
impact a significant amount of North
Carolinians oh it's not going to impact
a significant number of North
Carolinians well that's fine although by
that standard
you could also say we're going to
incinerate everyone named Warren that's
that's not a significant number of
people but you are gonna have a pretty
justifiably upset Warren Beatty on your
hands
that lore is significant to him because
not everyone actually does have ID in
Texas alone at least half a million
registered voters do not have the form
of ID necessary to vote
North Carolina and Wisconsin have
roughly three hundred thousand voters a
piece with neither a driver's license
nor a state ID and in Virginia an
estimated two hundred thousand voters
may not have one and if you think about
it
you probably know at least one person
who doesn't have an ID
whether it's your grandma who had her
license taken away you'll recluse uncle
who rollerblades everywhere or your
cousin who lost his license after his
third DUI come on Jase you can't fool a
breathalyzer by whispering the word
sober into it and even if you try to
obtain an ID just in order to vote it
can be difficult this thought a
Pennsylvania woman went through when her
state's ID law was in effect 68 year old
Doris Clarke was turned down three times
applying for her Pennsylvania voter ID
card and every time she says the state
wanted another document original birth
certificate original Social Security
card then she needed her husband's death
certificate when a clerk demanded proof
of her married name you feel like why am
I going through all these things I'm not
being man's wife bin Laden's wife is a
strange way to frame it why not say
Osama bin Laden was a Moll al saud
Osmond or see hamsa bars husband or
career Sabah's husband
hashtag Osama bin Laden hashtag feminism
yes and yet none of these difficulties
seem to trouble legislators like
Wisconsin's Joel Kleefisch who argued
for a strict ID law by pointing out his
state's photo ID requirement to buy
sudafed I find it frustrating that so
many of the same people who today are
telling us that a photo ID is just -
gosh darn much to maintain the integrity
of the ballot and those same people two
sessions ago made sure those same people
many of the same people in this room
made sure two sessions ago that you had
to have a photo ID to buy stuffy nose
medicine okay okay a couple of things
there first that bill was designed to
help curtail Wisconsin's meth problem
and second voting is a right if you take
it away you ruin democracy if you take
away someone's sudafed the only thing
you'll ruin is their sleeve and in some
parts of the country the offices that
issue IDs are hardly ever open in 2012 a
study found that in Wisconsin Alabama
and Mississippi fewer than half of all
ID issuing offices in the state are open
five days a week and in Sauk City
Wisconsin just a few districts over from
where that business casual Kevin Smith
lives the ID office is only open on the
fifth Wednesday of every month and only
four months in 2016 even have five
Wednesday's but don't worry there's a
rhyme March June August November have
five Wednesday's but remember if you
come on days not those you sell second
close
in Wisconsin
let's talk back there if you also
mentioned that studies have shown these
restrictions tend to disproportionately
impact African American and Latino
voters in Texas for instance experts
found that African American voters were
nearly twice as likely to lack voter ID
and Latinos were nearly two and a half
times as likely it is one of those
things that white people seem to be more
likely to have like a sunburn or an
Oscar nomination so what what are we
doing this well if you listen to the
legislators who help pass these laws
they'll say that they are necessary to
prevent fraud here is a co-sponsor of
Texas's voter ID law debbie riddle the
very freedom of our nation is based on
the integrity of our ballot box and if
things are so much that that fraudulent
voting can can occur that means your
phone can be stolen and simply showing
an identification it's not too much to
ask are you sure about that though don't
eat fish on the subway is not too much
to ask never start a facebook status
with that moment when there is not too
much to us requiring ID can actually be
asking a lot and and as for fraudulent
elections well let's look at that for a
moment because while American history is
littered with vote buying vote tampering
and ballot box stuffing voter ID doesn't
prevent those crimes
the only crime it prevents is voter
impersonation one person showing up to
the polls pretending to be someone
they're not which is a pretty stupid
crime because you have to stand in line
at a polling place and risk five years
in prison and a ten thousand dollar fine
all to cast one probably not
consequential extra vote in terms of
pointless crimes is right up there with
forging a Bed Bath & Beyond Cooper - lot
of troubled with low reward
yet people insist that this happens a
lot without photo ID what do you fear
could happen well without photo ID I
mean let's be clear I don't want dead
people voting in the state of South
Carolina I've said that from the very
beginning and authorities say there is
evidence that dead people voting is a
real problem according to a statewide
investigation by South Carolina's
Department of Motor Vehicles in January
it found that 953 ballots were cast by
voters who were deceased now that's true
the DMV did say that and the study calls
such a stir that one lawmaker stated we
must have certainty in South Carolina
that zombies aren't voting and look he's
right he's right no one wants that
except possibly for upstart candidate
Philip rose but but when the state's law
Enforcement Division investigated the
DMV's claims it found no real basis for
them in fact of the prior elections 207
suspicious ballots 92 of them were cases
where someone had the same name as a
deceased boat so usually a father and
son 56 of them were cases where the
Social Security number of a living voter
was mistakenly matched with a dead
person 32 was simply scanner errors one
person requested an absentee ballots
completed it and then died while it was
in the mail and and most of the others
were an array of random clerical errors
altogether the investigation found five
balance that could not be accounted for
this is an election where more than 1.3
million votes were cast these voter ID
laws are the biggest overreaction to a
manageable problem since Sleeping
Beauty's father ordered all the spinning
wheels in the lands to be burnt
this is the Korean economy we need those
wheels what do you just watch your
daughter for literally one day in her
keep life
voter impersonation fraud is incredibly
rare one researcher who tracked it
closely found that from 2000 to 2014
there were 31 possible incidents in the
entire country out of over a billion
ballots cast voter voter fraud is a
problem the way that deadly knife play
from crabs is a problem I'm not saying
it doesn't exist there are cases where
it has happened but let's not overreact
to one stabby crab these laws do
actually tend to make a little more
sense whenever you see someone slip up
and suggest other reasons for why they
may support them
voter ID which is gonna allow Governor
Romney to win the state of Pennsylvania
done do you think all the attention
drawn to voter ID effective last year's
elections yeah I think a little bit I
think we probably had a better election
think about this week I know about 5%
which was big a lot of people are cited
that he he won he beat McCain by 10
percent he beat Romney by 5 percent I
think that probably photo ID had a
helped a bit in that you know you're
saying the thing that everyone knows but
you're not supposed to say out loud
that's like writing I'm desperate to
bone on an online dating profile or a
band calling that reunion tour we ran
out of money but perhaps the most
galling thing here is that there there
are actual cases of voter impersonation
caught on camera and you will never
believe where they happen this is state
representative Debbie riddle she
authored the bill that would require
voters to show a photo ID clerk brain
develops a record vote it's all about
integrity record vote but the integrity
of one person one vote doesn't apply at
the legislature we found many lawmakers
vote more than once
take a look little votes turns around
votes again for state Rep temple rewind
and watch the men on the screen
Elkins goes to vote for merit but
Hancock is faster
Elkins heads back to his desk but before
he can vote Joe Crabb turns around and
beats him to it holy literally
competing to press other people's voting
buttons and remember this is Texas which
has the strictest ID laws in the country
and apparently this process is called
ghost voting and it happens in state
legislatures all over the country and
sometimes they involve literal ghost
votes one lawmaker in Texas died and was
it recorded voting three times
later that day which is clearly
ridiculous a real ghost wouldn't waste
its time voting on bills
it will be out terrorizing a young
family in their new house or trying
desperately to bang Demi Moore on a
pottery wheel one last time and and
debbie riddle is not the only voter ID
proponent who has done this
remember Wisconsin's Joel Kleefisch I
mean there is there is no way that he
got caught doing it right a cell phone
video posted online shows clay fish
placing a vote for an absent
Assemblymember clay fish says the online
video is an attempt at character
assassination no no no that's not
character assassination it's unedited
footage of something you obviously did
if anything that is character
auto-erotic asphyxiation and norma
lawmakers in tennessee are so shameless
about this they've got the whole thing
down to a fine art it's such a common
practice in the house in fact that many
lawmakers have sticks they use to reach
each other's voting buttons look
if you are going to pervert democracy
could you at least do it with a less
creepy stick what an evil leprechaun
would used to beat a child and yet
whatever legislators like debbie riddle
i asked about this actual voter
impersonation they say they've done
nothing wrong and only acting out of
necessity we have a lot of votes we have
a lot of amendments and there's times
when we don't break for lunch and we
don't break for dinner
we don't have bathroom breaks okay well
quick suggestion have you consider
getting some extra long voting sticks
they tend to help you know what at this
point I would like to propose something
any politician who has ever supported an
unnecessary voter ID law should be
forced to obtain a new ID every single
time they want to pass a bill just to
make sure they are who they say they are
and yes they might say well John that's
ridiculous there is no real reason to
make us do that and it's so cumbersome
it could prevent us from engaging in the
democratic process to which I would say
welcome to the Club
[Applause]